This right here is more valuable than a
$300 course on funnels because this is
the last funnel you are ever going to
need. I call it the ARMFunnel, okay? And
it stands for audience, relationship,
money. Those are the only three steps
that you need to build an online
business for yourself. Specifically, I
build businesses copywriting online,
writing online. Okay? So, if you were to
do it the way that I teach you and the
way that you could do it as well, you
want to focus on these three phases. And
I would do it in this exact structure.
Okay. Social media builds your audience.
You need to pick one social media
platform where your desired target
audience hangs out. Like for me, I'm
posting right here on YouTube because
this is where you guys hang out. And
then from there on social media, after
you spent content, after you've built
content building on social media, you
move those social media subscribers to
an email list. That can help you build a
deeper relationship. And it could also
help you retain the information of those
people cuz on social media it is rented
property. You don't know their email
address. You don't have their phone
number. You don't have anything like
that to contact them directly. So if
YouTube algorithm decides to crap out
tomorrow, well, I don't have a way to
reach my followers anymore. So instead,
I move them over to email where I can
own the relationship and build that
relationship. And then from there, you
send them a series of emails, once a day
or once a week, whatever. I do an email
once a day. And in every single email, I
make an offer, an offer to join my
community or buy my course or whatever.
And that offer makes me money. And that
is the only structure that I've ever
focused on in my three years of business
because it is so dead simple. Build an
audience on social media. Move them to
an email list. Make them an offer.
That's it.